bonjour à tous à chacune et à chacun
d'entre vous la tradition des vœux
invite à
identifier ce qui ne change pas et ce
qui change alors ce qui ne change pas
c'est par exemple le superbe panorama
des Pyrénées depuis la mairie de Pau et
c'est rassurant et c'est enthousiasmant
et puis ce qui change je change souvent
avec beaucoup de risques nous venons de
vivre
l'explosion de la guerre en Europe avec
l'agression de la puissante Russie sur
l'Ukraine pour l'annexer et pour la
soumettre et la résistance du crâne a
pour nous tous une signification très
importante
mais cette guerre a eu des conséquences
terribles des millions de réfugiés des
centaines de milliers de morts et puis
on parle même de déportation de prise
illégales d'enfants toutes choses qui
sont terrifiantes et inacceptables et
donc le la résistance des Ukrainiens et
notre résistance à tous et puis ça a
déclenché aussi une terrible crise
énergétique une terrible crise
monétaire d'inflation
de hausse des prix généralisées et tout
ceci est évidemment pour nous un
incroyable défi pour nos sociétés pour
l'Europe tout entière
l'incroyable défi
puis on entend des bruits qui sont
alarmants venus d'Extrême-Orient on voit
la situation de la Chine face à la
pandémie et puis on voit le délitement
des sociétés occidentales qui sont
parfois très durement déstabilisés je
pense aux États-Unis et nous en Europe
nous la France nous pourrions être dans
ce désordre mondial un point de repère
et un point de ralliement parce que nous
avons des valeurs qui sont précieuses
mais il faut corriger des difficultés
que nous avons faut corriger les
difficultés de l'école on peut pas
rester avec cette affaiblissement
perpétuel faut corriger les difficultés
du système de santé le fait qu'on ne
trouve plus de médicaments on avait fait
avec le Commissariat aux plans une
analyse sur ce sujet il y a près de deux
ans et voilà que ce que nous indiquions
c'est-à-dire y compris le doliprane mais
aussi les anti-inflammatoires mais aussi
les anticancéreux les antibiotiques
plus cela vient à manquer alors que nous
avons été très souvent les inventeurs de
ces produits pays de pointe placé
aujourd'hui dans des difficultés
inextricables parce que on a laissé
partir loin à la fabrication de ces
produits et puis le système de santé
la présence de médecins dans de
nombreuses spécialités de nombreuses
zones du territoire et puis il faut
résoudre la question de l'utilisation de
l'argent public c'était facile quand les
taux étaient à zéro c'était facile et
probablement utile quand les taux
étaient à zéro ne d'emprunter pour faire
mieux vivre et mieux produire le pays
aujourd'hui ça n'est plus le cas faut
qu'on s'occupe de l'organisation de
l'état des défis qui sont des défis
considérables et que nous pouvons
affronter alors simplement il faut
des qualités que nous devons mobiliser
la première même si surprend c'est
l'optimisme on ne fait rien si on a peur
et on ne franchit pas la montagne si on
n'est pas si on n'a pas la volonté
d'arriver au sommet deuxièmement c'est
la lucidité ça ne sert à rien de pousser
la poussière sous le tapis il faut de la
détermination pour résoudre les
questions qui se posent troisièmement il
faut une vertu que la France n'a pas
facilement il faut de l'unité et là
l'ADN du pays trop souvent c'est sa
division or il n'existe aucun pays dans
le monde qui réussit à survivre à la
division
intérieure intestine
si nous avons ces trois vertus
optimisme détermination unité alors je
n'ai pas de doute la France a affronter
de bien plus grave danger et elle
dépassera cela et si elle le fait à la
fois dans sa vie commune et dans
l'attention que nous portons les uns aux
autres parce que ça compte beaucoup de
faire des vœux personnels notamment pour
ceux qui rencontrent des difficultés si
nous avons cette attention les uns aux
autres en même temps que la volonté
commune et que la solidarité que nous
devons avoir entre nous alors je ne
doute pas que 2023 sera une très bonne
année pour la France et pour chacun
d'entre nous